well if you are celebrating vegan
you weary or dry january like ted is you
may need a little inspiration
rocky is live at a local one-stop shop
for vegan food products and a full juice
bar to replace that glass of wine rocky
yeah okay ted i've got a cocktail for
you okay this has got what
carrots spinach what else is in there
this is a special
juice it's got spinach carrots jalapeno
oh jalapenos you would have parsley
cucumber and celery
wow well this is a fully stocked juice
bar here at go vegan cafe
and this is a really great alternative
if you're taking out
if you're taking off alcohol right
trying to you know cleanse yourself get
ready for the new year
so tell us why juicing is so important
for the body well juicing is very
important for the body it does a lot of
our cleansing and
puts the minerals in if you're going on
a fast
it keeps you without hunger gives you
adds minerals to it
it's important it's important and and
you can make you can get creative with
it like i said it's a cocktail you can
look at all those
menu items right there you can put all
of that in a juice everything works
right
everything and we have some specific
ones like
beet and ginger which is very popular in
apple yeah and i want to mention that
you mentioned what you guys have a juice
cleanse here so let's talk about what
you offer
everybody who wants to start healthy
well we offer a juice cleanse but it
consists of four juices and
uh two shots of uh either aloe vera
or uh ginger and then we also bought all
for a bottle of water it's like a kid
and it's a discounted price
well and of course as we're dealing with
covid this is something really important
it it you heal yourself from the inside
out
exactly keeping your immune system going
because that's the most important thing
in the body keeps everybody awake
definitely and lastly here before let's
let's pour some drinks i want to have a
cocktail
with you um i want to know you mentioned
earlier the biggest animals are vegan
exactly and that goes to show just
because you think vegan food you're
going to be
hungry later you're not depleted from a
protein that's what everybody's worried
about
where do i get my protein right well
from your greens
there you go there you go all right you
ready bottom's up
all right cheers to be january and to a
healthy 20-21
oh this is good and i can handle the
house the jalapeno
i'll send it back to you guys